You've been forced into
another high school death game and
all of your classmates are dying again.
You're the only one that knows
what's about to happen,
and you'll need to use your knowledge
to escape certain death
when the death game keeps repeating itself
until you die. What do you do?
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do
and how to beat Kings game. Part two.
The ultimate nightmare has returned.
Nobu here has just started his first day
at a new high school.
His memories of the deadly Kings game
he played in his previous
school haunt him.
And he's become a social recluse.
He's assigned to sit right next to
the most popular girl in class, Natsuko.
And out of coincidence,
she happens to share the same last
name as his girlfriend
who died in the previous game.
By the end of the day,
Nobu begins to line up and starts
to forget about all the horrible stuff
he experienced in the last Kings game.
But his peace of mind
doesn't last too long.
That night, Nobu here
gets a text on his phone while in bed.
A message informs him
that he and the rest of his new classmates
have been entered into the Kings game.
All orders must be obeyed in 24 hours,
and quitting the game is not an option.
The first order by the king
is for Nobu here and the girl he met
earlier Natsuko to kiss before
midnight of the next day.
The death game has begun.
OK, if I'm Nobu,
I would be freaking the hell out.
I've already been through
one Kings game before and watched
all of my friends brutally die.
Not only that, I've witnessed
my girlfriend sacrificed herself
for my safety, leaving me
an emotional wreck.
Luckily for me, I know
what's coming next is deadly,
which means we need to take action now
to save my own life.
My first priority would be to convince
the rest of my class
that this game is not a prank.
And I'm not just some creepy guy who wants
to make out with hot chicks, dawg.
Now, it would make sense here
to consider for a moment
not to tell anyone at all
about the Kings game being real.
That way, more students
will be likely to die quickly
from not following the orders early on.
And I'd have less competition.
But unfortunately,
the first order of the game
was given to us,
which means we can't use this strategy.
As soon as we obey
the king, we'll let everyone else know
that we follow the order.
The better thing to do here
is to tell everyone about the Kings game
and complete our order,
but then at the same time,
keep some of the details a secret so that
I could use those later to my advantage.
And proving that this game is real
can be done very easily. At Nobu's.
Previous school Thirty-One students
brutally died throughout
the course of a few days,
and he was the only survivor.
I'm sure there would have been widespread
national coverage of these deaths
and multiple police investigations.
Well, the police and media
might have hid his identity
for privacy reasons, since he's a minor.
He still has plenty of provable evidence
that he was involved.
If it were me, all I need to do
is show my new classmates photos of me
and my friends in my former classroom
and the media coverage
of these incidents happening.
And they'd probably be scared
enough to believe me if that doesn't work.
Why not just get out my phone, assuming
I haven't got a new phone,
I can just show them
text of the previous game
and all the crazy punishments
dished out to my old classmates.
The next day, all of the classmates
gather round to discuss the texts
they've received.
Most of them think it's some silly way
for Nobu here to get in on his crush
and who can blame them.
Nobu knows that he's in store
for another death game
and he can't handle the thought
of playing through it again.
So he volunteered to be the first victim
and is willing to die and take Natsuko
down with him in the process.
He goes to the school's
baseball field to wait out the punishment
for failing his order.
But luckily for him, Natsuko
happens to find him and they share a kiss.
When the clock hits midnight,
they receive a text with two words
obedience confirmed.
Looks like they made it
just in the nick of time.
Now that the first order is complete,
it's time for the real games to begin.
A dozen orders are sent
to different members of the class, ranging
from licking feet
to straight up killing fellow classmates.
Not only that, two rules are set for
the next 24 hours, which can't be broken.
No one can do anything the king
considers forbidden, and no one in
the class is allowed to fall asleep.
Sadly, for too early sleepers,
their lives have just been brutally ended.
This game is no joke.
More tech start coming in
and people are dropping like flies.
Nobu here runs off to the closest
classmates house.
Rushing in, he realizes it's too late.
The Kings game has begun its death spree,
but the Kings game is
not for the weak hearted.
Nobu gets a text saying
that the six other students have all been
given savage punishments,
each dying in their own gruesome ways.
This is terrifying,
but we have knowledge and knowledge
is power in a situation like this.
We already know from the first game
that the king is
not a person in our class,
nor is the king a person at all.
If I'm Nobu, I'm
remembering what the white haired
girl here told us back in the first game.
Based on her research,
she found that the king is a virus
that has the power to hypnotize people
into doing crazy shit that will kill you.
She's also told us
that the virus has the ability to evolve
and become more contagious over time.
Look, if I'm just a high school student
and I want to survive this deadly game
from repeating over and over,
I'm going to need some help from adults.
Professionals, that means the police
and expert computer scientists.
The first thing I would do
is to contact the nearby police station
and get immediate assistance.
I would create a fake email address
posing as a serial killer
who's threatening to kill me.
I would send emails from that account
to deliver at certain times
over the course of a week
to make sure my fake killer
is as convincing as possible. With these
threats, I could request the police
to give our class 24/7 surveillance.
If they witness the punishments,
they have much more resources
they can use to stop the virus.
And 24/7 surveillance
might be enough to stop us
from doing anything dangerous to ourselves
if we were to fail in order.
With Japan having one of the lowest murder
rates in the world and nine students
already dead, this would easily be
one of the biggest murder
cases to ever come out of the country.
The only one greater murder case in recent
memory would be the first Kings game
that we just went through.
Since I'm the only survivor
from the first Kings game,
I should definitely be
a person of interest in this case
and could easily get the attention
of the media or police if I had to.
As far as I know, telling outsiders about
the game isn't breaking the rules.
I could use the media as a platform
to let people know
that the king is not a person,
but in fact a virus and call on scientists
to handle the rest.
Gathering the survivors to the park, Nobu
finally reveals to the class
that this is not his first rodeo.
Nobu has been involved with the Kings
game once before and was the only survivor
after winning the game.
He explains to them that disobeying
the rules can mean death,
and they start to panic.
But their panic turns to anger
when they find out the Nobu didn't
want to kiss Natsuko, meaning
they both would have failed their orders
and died after the clock
hit midnight out of rage.
This blond guy here attacks Nobu
before receiving a gruesome punishment.
Suddenly, the blond guy's body implodes
with dozens of bloody
whores, his eyes popping out of his face,
falling to the ground dead.
It turns out that attacking other
classmates was what the king
deemed forbidden.
Natsuko reveals that her next order
is to have sex with this spiky
haired student, knowing she will die.
If she doesn't follow the order,
she cries and Nobu's, arms
and asks for him to help.
Nobu tries to comfort her.
But when she asks him
if there's a way to escape, all he can say
is that she must follow the order.
Hearing this, Natsuko suddenly
pulls a complete 180, getting a crazed
look in her eye.
She takes down the spiky haired
guy, gets rid of her shirt and insist
they do it right here
in front of everyone,
and that she'll do whatever
it takes to win,
and that Nobu is useless to her
if he doesn't know
a way to escape the game.
But then pulling another switch
just before she completes the order,
she takes NOBL away for a talk in private.
And this idiot goes with her
being the good guy
that he is and not realizing
what he's getting himself into.
Nobody here tries to tell her
that they need to work together,
but she doesn't agree.
She says that the game has only one winner
and is survival of the fittest.
Her attitude towards the situation
gives him a hint that she might have been
a part of a previous Kings
game out of nowhere.
She screams out for help,
as if Nobu is coming on to her.
The classmates arrive and beat him down.
Noticing that nobody here is in trouble,
this board, a guy here, takes him away.
Along with this blue haired
girl, the sports guy here
reveals that he has received
an order to become the king for one order.
So he sends a text to himself
ordering to protect the blue haired girl
from harm to make her feel safe.
OK, with one third of our class dead.
Emotions are running hot
in high pressure situations.
It's common for people
to lose their ability to think clearly.
And Natsuko here
is taking full advantage of that.
This girl just pulled a complete 180
on Nobu here twice and still fooled
everyone into thinking he's a creep.
She'll do whatever it takes to survive.
And right now, she's playing
everyone like a fiddle.
If I'm Nobu here, this girl
just became my number one opponent.
He's too busy trying to be
kind and helpful
when he should know
better than anyone else that
the can only be one winner in this game.
And it nearly cost him his life.
But the situation
is actually much worse than that.
Not only is Natsuko
willing to win at all costs,
she sees Nobu as a major threat
as he was being beaten up.
She tried to manipulate this blue haired
girl who was given the power by the king
for a day to kill two students
by sending them a text with the word die.
Natsuko Logit told the blue haired girl
to kill Nobu on the spot.
And if not for the sheer
luck of the sport,
a guy intervening at the last moment
and the blue haired girl realizing
what she's about to do and breaking
her own phone, Nobu would be dead.
If it were me. This sport
guy's order is my ticket to eliminating
Natsuko before she gets a chance
to pull any other stunts.
I would type in order into his phone
for the entire class
while he's too distracted
from carrying me.
It would say every student
except a Nobu must immediately die.
I would then tell him he dropped his phone
and hand it back to him,
pushing the send button
with his thumb to send the kill order
to every student, including him.
There can only be one winner,
and I'm not taking any chances
with keeping this level of competition
within the game.
The sooner Nobu realizes
Natsuko and everyone else or a threat
that he has no choice but to deal
with the better after they escape.
Nobu here explains the situation
they're in and where the king's game
originated from a place called Yanakie.
Village was the birthplace of the game,
the three decide to go to the village
to find clues on how to beat the game.
On the way, Mizuki
replaces her broken phone and the group
travels by train to Yanakie
Village at Yanakie Village.
Nobu finds a picture of his dead
girlfriend from the first game
and her father in one of the houses
exiting the place.
He finds a dead body
with another picture beside it.
This time, it's the father
holding two babies, finding two names
on the back of the picture.
He finds the Natsuko
and his dead girlfriend.
We're sisters, and the dead body
he found is their father.
So that's why they both
had the same last name.
This information
lets him confirm that Natsuko is, in fact,
also a Kings game survivor.
He also finds out that their father was in
the first ever Kings game.
Meanwhile, techs are sent out
showing that seven more students
have been brutally murdered by the king
in a matter of three days.
Half the class has been wiped out
since the village is pretty remote.
The blue haired girl and the sports guy
go to the nearest radio tower
to get a phone signal in order to complete
their orders when they reach the tower.
The sporty guy knocks her out and sends
the text with the word die to himself
and not to go from her new phone,
not knowing that the text must be sent
from the original phone.
The blue haired girl is sentenced to death
for disobedience,
while the sporty guy here is sentenced
to death for failing to protect her .
While all this craziness is going
on, classmates continue to die.
This girl here has been given an order
to be groped by another classmate,
but he's already dead.
Another girl has been ordered
to lose something important
as she brutally murders her parents
and is about to do the unthinkable,
but gives up leading to her death
with both of his friends dead.
Nobu tries calling his spiky haired
classmate for help, but Natsuko
picks up the phone
and tells him that she has taken
both the phone and the spiky haired
boy hostage in order to complete her order
and for her own amusement.
She mocks him for trying to kill her
from the wrong phone and informs him
that she is even holding
his own phone, too.
Without their phones, Nobu and the spiky
haired guy can't play and are sure to die.
Desperate, Nobu tries looking for clues.
And that's when he remembers
that players of this game
and the previous one were given
the mysterious single syllable text
that may lead to some answers.
Natsuko takes the chance to gather
everyone at a park where they discuss
the next order that they just received.
And it's to play a brutal game in
the order of their classroom seat numbers.
They must take turns
breaking their own fingers in each turn.
Any student may break
as many of their own fingers as they wish.
Breaking a right hand
finger is worth one positive point
that you can assign to anyone.
And breaking a left hand
finger is worth one negative point
that you can assign to anyone.
Whoever has a negative point total
at the end of the game will be punished.
And if they want, players
have the ability to pass on their turn.
The game ends after each
player has taken one turn.
So we now know for sure
that Natsuko has been in a previous game
just like Nobu here.
This means she's dangerous
because you don't beat the Kings game
without going through
some heavy mental trauma.
And we need to be treating her
as a very serious threat and take action
to eliminate her as soon as possible
before the game starts.
I would tell everyone
about all the crazy information
I've just gathered on my little trip
to Yanakie Village.
I tell them this convince them
that at this point
we all need to be working together
to take Natsuko down.
She's a complete liability
to the rest of us,
and we know she's prepared to do
the most savage things to win this game.
And we know that her father
was in the original game.
She herself has been in two games
and her sister was in the previous game.
It's like a little Kings
Game family reunion
where none of the family members
come back alive.
Looking at this game,
there's a lot of strategy involved,
but it can be boiled down
to a few simple concepts.
First, the last player
to go holds the most power
because after their turn the game.
And so no one can undo their moves
and anyone with the negative points
immediately dies.
Secondly, collaboration
gives you a lot of power.
For example, in four players
against three players,
the four players can give
20 negative points by breaking
all of their left hand fingers.
This will give each of the three opponents
six or seven negative points,
which means even all five of their
right hand fingers
won't be enough to save themselves.
But the most important thing
to understand about this game
is that even using these strategies
to gain an advantage, it's
almost impossible
to prevent someone from taking revenge.
Once you've doomed them to die,
if they still have a turn left.
If, however, you
team up against two players,
they might not be able to save themselves,
but they can both work together
to kill one of your teammates,
which is exactly why I wouldn't
play this game by the rules at all,
because we need to think outside of
the box here instead of playing this game.
I would get all of my classmates together
and pen not to go down to the ground by
now. The death game rules
against violence being forbidden
for 24 hours is already over.
And we can convince the remaining players
that she's been evil the whole way through
and that she doesn't deserve
any more chances.
And even if she has one or two friends
that are on her side,
the rest of the class will be.
Too much for them to fight off.
They start playing
and most of the students team up and agree
to past their turn, including Nobu here
after his friend asks, tend to trust them.
That's when this spiky haired guy
who was taken hostage and his phone taken
by Natsuko decides
to break one of his positive fingers
and all five of his negative fingers.
He then threatens to use
all of his negative points on Natsuko
unless he gets his phone back from her.
She then gives the phone back and he ends
up giving one positive point to our guy
Nobu for negative points to Natsuko,
and one negative point to not who
best friend with everyone else passing
and the last player looking hesitant.
And looks like this leaves Natsuko and her
best friend as the loser of the game,
but Natsuko has one last
trick up her sleeve.
The last person to go
is Natsuko's best friend
who is reluctant to break her fingers
before she can make a decision.
Natsuko does it for her and smashes
four of the fingers on her positive hand.
Somehow she also manages
to convince the best friend
to give her more positive points,
which means she's now safe,
but she's not done.
As Natsuko Conley breaks her best friend's
remaining positive finger and saves
the best friend from ending the game
with a negative point total,
no one ends up with a negative point total
and the order is complete.
OK, I think it's pretty obvious here.
The Natsuko best friend is suffering
from a severe case of Stockholm syndrome,
which is a psychological response
that happens when victims of abuse
develop a bond with their abuser,
which is more common than you think.
Either way, Natsuko's friend can't be
trusted to work with the rest of the team.
Now we don't have time to reason
with our friend.
And it looks like her and Natsuko
have been friends for years now,
and none of us have
the psychiatric experience
to stop her from going to the dark side.
But Natsuko here made a critical mistake
when her turn came
to break her own fingers.
She passed thinking she was safe
to use her friends to get back the points
as soon as her turn was over.
All it would take is two more broken left
fingers to give Natsuko negative six
points, and then there would be nothing
her friend could have done to save her.
With only five fingers on her right hand,
there's no time limit on this game.
So if it came down to just me and Natsuko
friend remaining, I would get some ice
pain meds and a hammer
and do what's necessary to ensure
the game gives her a painful death.
The class gathers again
near the river, except for Natsuko.
They all agreed to work as a group
to beat the Kings game.
Suddenly, our spiky haired friend here
begins bleeding from all over.
To the surprise of no one, Natsuko has
struck again before giving the phone back.
She goes into spiky haired guys
phone and blocks the king.
Blocking the king on your phone
is the same as quitting the game,
and the rule set from the start is broken.
No quitting allowed.
His head explodes
off of his body, killing him.
This short kid comes running back with
a present for the guy, but it's too late.
And in a state of shock, he tries, putting
the hat he bought onto the spiky hair.
The guys had less body.
The next order is given
without being allowed to use any vehicles.
The class must run to the top
of the nearest mountain.
Every time, eight hours past,
the furthest member from the top will die
until everyone reaches the finish line.
Nobu takes a long Riona and this headband
guy here, the three run to the top.
But after a few hours, Nobu's.
Classmates begin to fade,
realizing he's not fit enough to make it.
Headband guy jumps
into the ocean as Nobu tries,
but ultimately fails to save him
as he disappears into the ocean.
I guess that means he wanted
to drown in his sorrows.
Later on, Nobu figures out
that he and Riona are in last place
before another eight hour window passes.
Nobu purposefully keeps himself in last
place on purpose so the girl can survive.
But in a strange series of events,
the guy that fell in the ocean and drowned
earlier ends up receiving the punishment,
being very unfit.
Nobu and Riona are once again
minutes away from death.
They're way too far behind to catch up,
and one of them will die as another
eight hours pass.
But luckily for them,
Natsuko's friend here ran
the opposite direction, meaning
when the eight hour window finally passes
again, she takes the punishment
as her head flies off of her body.
Eventually, Natsuko is the first
to reach the top of the mountain
as typical for her.
She manages to track three of the
classmates into suffering brutal deaths
shortly after Nobu arrives with Riona,
along with a short kid and glasses girl,
as only five students managed to complete
the order when they reached the top.
They receive a new order, cut off
parts of their body to make a human doll.
The body parts can be given
from one person or multiple people.
The short kid here has a psychotic break
and knocks out Nobu
with a rock to the head.
He offers his own limbs
up to complete the order.
Natsuko then obliges
and cut his leg off with a chainsaw.
Seeing this glasses girl attacks,
her butt is sliced straight in the chest
and bleeds out OK
out of all the orders we've gotten.
This is the craziest one
so far at this point.
The best way to survive
the king's game is to stop
playing altogether and treat this
like the battle royale. It always was.
Firstly, I would be way more on
edge around the short kid.
He seems like a nice person,
but he just watched his best friend's head
explode off of his body yesterday.
He's probably not in the most
mentally stable condition at the moment
and should be watched at all costs.
Tensions are high right now.
And these are. My classmates,
but I've only known them for about a week.
This might sound cold blooded, but
there's a big fat chainsaw right there.
We're on top of a mountain
where no CCTV footage would catch us.
I would grab the chainsaw and pretend
to take the bullet for the group.
When they let their guard down,
I would slice Natsuko in half
like a gorgeous ham slice.
I'm sure the rest would in mind,
but I'm not stopping there.
In the midst of celebrating Natsuko death,
I would take out the others
and go on my very merry way.
Apart from Natsuko,
I'm the most knowledgeable person
when it comes to the Kings game
by winning the game.
I could use my past experiences
to tell top scientists, researchers
and whoever else about the dangers
of this virus and how fast it can evolve.
Based on the events in Yanakie Village,
we know that the game can be
hosted in places other than a classroom.
If the game continues to spread,
it might wipe out entire countries
in the years to come.
So if you think about it,
I'm really killing my classmates here
for the greater good
after seeing the chaos they've caused.
The remaining three stop fighting and
decide to get to the bottom of this game.
They remember that
everyone who dies while playing
the game gets a single syllable text
sent to them before they're punished.
By combining the syllables,
they find a message that says
and the game by ending your life,
even if one survives.
The Kings game won't end
until humanity is destroyed.
The King virus sure
has a dark sense of humor.
Realizing that the game
will never be beaten,
Natsuko here attacks the main character.
Suddenly she gets a chainsaw
to the spine from her yoona,
and the madness looks to be all over.
Viena then has a romantic moment
and confesses her love to Nobu here before
being rudely interrupted with a chainsaw
through the throat as Natsuko
briefly comes back from the dead.
Both of them fall to the ground
while bleeding out.
Speaking her final words, Natsuko admits
that she's also in love with Nobu
because of how similar
he was to her old boyfriend.
However, in a matter of seconds,
they both die due to blood loss.
Nobu arrives in the afterlife,
where he reunites with his girlfriend,
who died in the previous game.
The rest of his fallen classmates
look on at him before
Natsuko appears again, this time
looking to be at peace with herself.
And the group wanders
off into the horizon.
Only one person remains
Riona here takes the dead body
of the main character to the beach.
As they share a final romantic moment
together, she kisses him
and finds that his body has gone
completely cold.
Realizing that there's
nothing left for her,
she carries his lifeless body
into the ocean before disappearing.
It looks like she chose not to continue
sometime in the future.
Life has gone back to normal.
Before long, a brown haired
student receives
a text from a mysterious number
that says this is the king's game.
All members of your class
will participate.
You have 24 hours to carry them out.
The games have only just begun.
And if you don't want your brown
haired friend getting you
caught up in a king's game, then subscribe
for dear life like comet comment.
Let us know what you liked
and of course, didn't like,
but be nice about it and check out
how to be playlist downbelow.